l'issue de cette mobilisation une
question emmanuel macron doit-il
redoutés chiffres la colère sociale
on en parle avec nos deux invités celle
des bacs ce soir et nous savons avec
yves d'amécourt conseiller régional la
du mouvement de la ruralité renouvelle
aquitaine et michel larive député la
france soumise de l'ariège bonsoir
messieurs et merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur arte france
quel bilan tirez vous tous les deux de
ce défilé du 1er mai on va commencer
avec vous michel larive ces temps de
poser la question est ce que je suis
président de la république a à craindre
une colère une colère populaire en
colère sociale oui le 1er mai la montre
est ce que vous allez montrer les gens
se sont exprimés et il ya plusieurs
thématiques là dessus les gens peuvent
être en colère s'il rate encore une fois
son déconfinement puisque ça engendrera
faisait bien un restaurateur ça
engendrera un des faillites du chômage
s'est faite de plus petits bien entendu
aujourd'hui ont des confine au sol on a
confiné à l'automne donc c'est plein dès
qu'on filme en politique
une colère sociale si il fait payer la
crise et la dette de cette crise aux
plus pauvres
pendant que notamment 51 milliards de
dividendes sont versés au cac 40
s'il persiste dans sa politique
d'austérité ont voulant réformer
effectivement les retraites l'assurance
chômage retraite par capitalisation qui
serait maintenant calculée sur toute une
vie plus plus sur 25 ans 10 sur six mois
pour le pour le public l'assurance
chômage
je donne juste un exemple rotation au
chômage c'est un smicard demain à partir
du 1er juillet touchera 667 euros
d'allocations chômage au lieu de 1 965
aujourd'hui voyez en bref s'il applique
une politique d'austérité
à contre-courant des grandes démocraties
dans ce monde notamment baye dame qui
dit lui qu'il pose 2000
yar de dollars sur la table pour
relancer notamment la la commande la
commande publique et ses 2000 milliards
ne participe pas d'un plan de relance il
a autre chose pour le plan de relance
et oui aussi s'il continue à aggraver la
fracture sociale dans notre pays
s'il continue à poser des lois
liberticides tel de loi séparatisme que
j'ai passé dans notre hémicycle s'il
continue à diffuser châtiment des effets
de stigmatisation près de 1000
communautés religieuses ici en france
c'est à dire 5 millions de français qui
sont stigmatisés quasiment tous les
jours s'il continue à poser la loire et
anti républicaine notamment sur la
réforme de la loi 1905 et s'il continue
lui aussi à stigmatiser une partie de la
classe politique est là en ce faisant
ils jouent le jeu de ceux qui veulent qu
il veut combattre notamment les
terroristes les terroristes cherchent à
fracturer la société française depuis le
début de l'heure de leurs actions
terroristes
eh bien ils sont en train d'y arriver
grâce à tous à tous cet effet qui est en
train de se mettre en place c'est à dire
que l'on stigmatise le gouvernement y
participent monsieur vide à madame villa
blanquetière monsieur darmanin qui le
traîne nous déciderons gauchistes les
universités aussi les jeunes aussi et
donc à partir de ce moment ça joue le
jeu effectivement terroristes islamiques
qui n'en demandait pas tant et je crois
que s'ils continuent là dedans à un
moment donné persévérer dans cette
chose-là en connaissant la conséquence
c'est à dire la fracture de notre
société
à ce moment là il va y avoir une forme
de complicité et je crois que
effectivement il peut craindre une grave
colère sociale
c'est tous ces éléments sa ligne alors à
ce moment-là on peut craindre le pire
oui effectivement une mobilisation du
1er mai placée sous le signe de la
convergence des luttes
yves d'amécourt qu'est ce que ça dit
dans ce climat social en france est ce
que vous vous attendez vous aussi
notamment avec le déconfinement mais
peut-être un peu plus longtemps avec la
rentrée
de septembre à ce qu'il faut s'attendre
un nouveau mouvement social d'envergure
écoutez je crois que aujourd'hui la
france ne va pas bien
moi je suis agriculteur et il ya quinze
jours
nos productions ont subi le gel et les
aléas climatiques et ça dans toute la
france l'année dernière les agriculteurs
ont fait des plans en garde et des prêts
garantis par l'état pour suppléer le
manque de chiffre d'affaires due au
cours d'un virus aujourd'hui on leur
propose de faire de nouveaux prêts
garantis par l'état pour remplacer la
récolte qu'ils n'auront pas les artisans
les commerçants le la crise des gilets
jaunes
elle s'est arrêtée avec le corona virus
mais elle existe toujours
parce que comme l'a rappelé la personne
que vous avez interrogé dans votre
reportage
les problèmes n'ont pas changé ils n'ont
pas été résolus et puis on a un
président de la république et un premier
ministre qui ne nous donne pas
d'espérance qu'il ne nous donne pas de
vision de l'endroit où il veut aller
donc je vois pas comment est-ce que à la
fin de l'été quand tout le monde aura
été vaccinées quand nous aurons atteint
atteint la limite et collectives promise
je ne vois pas comment cette france peut
continuer à regarder passer les trains
sans se rebeller et donc je pense que
dans tous les domaines dans tous les
milieux aujourd'hui les gens sont
enfermés
parce qu'il ya la crise sanitaire mais à
la rentrée de septembre après après
l'été quand tout le monde sera vacciné
je pense que les revendications seront
nombreuses et que le gouvernement ne
pourra plus reculés et advitam eternam
toutes les toutes les promesses que le
président a fait en 2017 lors de
l'élection présidentielle il va falloir
faire vraiment des choses concrètes pour
que chacun retrouve l'envi d'espérer il
va y avoir une augmentation du chômage
très importante
un certain nombre de personnes qui
aujourd'hui sont sous perfusion de
l'état liées à la crise sanitaire
vont perdre cette perfusion notamment
des très petites entreprises je suis
aussi vice président de la fédération
des très petites entreprises
on est très inquiet parce que quand les
aides vont arrêter l'activité ne
reprendra pas et un certain nombre
d'acteurs économiques essentiels de
notre pays qui sont très nombreux qui
sont moins visibles que air france ou
que des grands groupes qui aujourd'hui
sont aider massivement par l'état eh
bien vous n'auront pas d'autre choix que
que de manifester leur mécontentement et
est on est on est au bord de quelque
chose qui peut ressembler à de la guerre
civile
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui a été annoncé
par le cette tribune des généraux et des
militaires il ya quelques jours où ces
gens qui ont la nation ancrée au coeur
disent attention à nos gouvernants
faites attention parce que vous êtes en
train de créer les conditions d'une
guerre civile
je vois réagir michel larive sur cette
question d'une possible guerre civile
alors l'expression on l'a entendu
revenir tout au long de cette journée on
va un peu loin là qu'est ce que vous en
pensez mais monsieur vient de valider
mes propos d'avant il vient de parler de
cette tribune de généraux factieux voyez
c'est très très grave
là est le problème normalement le
président de la république il est garant
de la cohésion de la cohésion sociale
donc et la cohésion de notre nation ceux
là aujourd'hui en nano en marchant sur
les plates bandes notamment de l'extrême
droite en stigmatisant une partie de la
population il fait ce jeu il donne une
certaine impunité à des actes racistes
et antisémites qui se multiplient la
tentative 1 à dole d'écraser un monsieur
volontairement ces choses là là c'est
encore ces derniers jours les attaques
dans les mosquées
et puis d'autres acteurs ont ici mito
city ce qui se multiplient la
banalisation de discours d'extrême
droite et notamment cette se fait
d'impunité des généraux maintenant en ce
qu'ils peuvent
ils peuvent bien mais qui peut se lâcher
qui peuvent dire ce qu'ils viennent de
faire heureusement le chef d'état-major
des armées lui a remis tout ça en place
et en tout en toute action républicaine
il a dénoncé
il a dénoncé cette tribune je la dénonce
fortement parce que tout ceci participe
de quelque chose d' anti républicain
possible
je pense que le président de la
république et le gouvernement doit se
ressaisir très très vite parce que
aujourd'hui ils sont en train de mettre
la france au danger véritablement il
faut qu'il serait saisi de la chose
républicaine de nos fondements liberté
égalité fraternité voici nos fondements
et le ciment de tout ça sur la laïcité
est ce que c'est la gestion de la sortie
de crise à parme et emmanuel macron alex
déconfinement qui se rapprochent c'est
ce que cela peut changer la donne yves
d'amécourt en ce ce déconfinement
annoncé est encore un un espèce de
processus bureaucratique que personne ne
comprend un tableau à 50 entrées 56,50
ordonné ou chacun doit retrouver la
casse dans laquelle il se trouve tout ça
aide
éminemment compliqué comme le discours
du président qui a l'habitude de dire à
chacun ce qu'il a envie d'entendre quand
tout le monde se retrouve autour de la
table on s'aperçoit qu'il a dit des
choses contraires à chacun et donc ça ne
peut pas fonctionner on n'a pas de chef
en fait dans cette danse est dans ce
pays et si on n'a pas un chef d'état si
on a pas quelqu'un qui fait autorité et
bien le régime va devenir autoritaire et
c'est parce que nous voulons est donc
aujourd'hui à quoi s'intéresse le
président de la république
de quoi parlent les micros cause le
parisien on parle de changer le premier
ministre ah oui c'est très intéressant
donc en fait l'avenir des français
l'avenir de l'économie française
l'avenir des petites entreprises des
agriculteurs l'avenir des ouvriers
l'avenir des industries ça n'intéresse
pas grand monde là haut ils sont en
train de faire des plans sur la comète
sur savoir qui sera le prochain premier
ministre
voilà ce qui intéresse aujourd'hui nos
gouvernants et donc on est toujours dans
la petite politique politicienne et tout
ça est très dangereux parce que le pays
a besoin d'espérance
monsieur citait les valeurs de la
république la liberté l'égalité la
fraternité
où est-elle aujourd'hui la liberté où
est-elle aujourd'hui la fraternité où
est-elle aujourd'hui l'égalité et puis
alors quant à la laïcité alors n'en
parlons pas aujourd'hui on est en train
d'essayer de bricoler tout ça le
président souhaite modifier la loi de
1905 qui est un des piliers de notre de
notre république et il faut pas il faut
pas bricoler avec ses grandes lois qui
sont aujourd'hui des repères pour la
population et pour la nation et donc si
on veut que la nation soit soudée il
faut autre chose que ce qui est proposé
aujourd'hui il faut vraiment à la fois
des raisons d'espérer et ensuite une
méthode pour y arriver pour sortir de
l'ornière dans lequel nous sommes enfin
je lisais un article juste avant cette
édition le temps du mandat du sénégal en
terme de crise sanitaire
aujourd'hui le sénégal est l'occasion
d'en reparler
pour l'organisation de la crise
sanitaire on est en retard sur tout mais
ce sera le mot de la fin malheureusement
messieurs le temps nous manque michel
larive voulais te dire un tout dernier
vous avez vraiment 30 secondes
non mais je le donne et je le dis tout à
l'heure je souhaite véritablement que le
gouvernement se ressaisisse
nous avons besoin maintenant de
convictions sociales et j'espère
j'espère qu'il va réussir sont des
nombreux sondés confinement pour
justement ne pas aboutir à un recond
finement parce que l'on là je pense
qu'il y aura un rien le problème et nous
aurons l'occasion évidemment de
reprendre ces sujets merci à tous les
deux
ils d'amécourt conseil régional du
mouvement de la ruralité en nouvelles
aquitaine et michel larive député de la
france insoumise de l'ariège merci
d'avoir participé à cet échange et à
très bientôt sur arte france